qu'est ce que vous foutez dans le coin
bande d'écervelés danse pas mouiller on
trouve des personnes comme moi et les
pauvres merde dans ton genre si tu
restes dans et les personnes comme moi
boufflers genton l'espace intérieur
moi c'est pas l'heure j'assure de cochon
sauvage et légendes du bush australien
tu débarques dans mon pays
tous fait des petites affaires comme si
tu étais seul maître à bord du brise un
prédateur de sa proie
et tu crois pouvoir repartir comme si de
rien n'était tu fais mienne
et on en trouve ici malfaisante
permettra une saleté le parasite
c'est aux gens de mon espèce de
supprimer votre race de dégénérer c'est
bon manche
il va falloir faire mieux que ça
on voit bien que tu connais pas la règle
numéro un de la pas un jour où il ne
faut jamais jamais s'arrêter